après la conférence du président de la
république et après votre séminaire
gouvernemental du flou toujours du flou
mais pas sur le dérapage des déficits
publics au moment où la croissance
faiblit
vous avez fait le choix de creuser le
déficit
comme l'indiquait un ancien rapporteur
général de la cour des comptes interrogé
suite à vos annonces
le déficit public se dégrade et votre
politique budgétaire menacent la
cohérence de la zone euro à long terme
pourtant le candidat emmanuel macron le
disait lui même ne pas réduire nos
dépenses courantes et notre dette serait
irresponsable pour les générations à
venir
il avait raison mais deux ans après ces
belles paroles
l'état dépense encore plus que sous la
présidence de françois hollande il faut
tout de même le faire et sans faire
d'économies structurelles
en effet vous supprimez 23 milliards de
taxe d'habitation comment en finance et
surtout quels sont les compensations
pour les collectivités locales fin 2018
vous tenté d'acheter la paix sociale
avec un chèque de 10 milliards
et aujourd'hui vous annoncer 5 milliards
de réductions d'impôts là encore comment
on finance la réalité c'est que c'est la
dette qui paye ses de l'impôt c'est de
l'impôt pour nos enfants
sur qui vous vous déresponsabilisez vous
aviez promis le réenchantement une
révolution destinée à construire la
prospérité du 21e siècle
le soulèvement populaire récent le
déclassement d'une partie des français
l'inquiétude de nos concitoyens pour
leur avenir illustre l'effondrement de
cette illusion
alors monsieur le premier ministre
quelle france voulez vous transmettre
aux générations futures
et quel est votre objectif de dette pour
la fin du quinquennat
la parole est à monsieur olivier
augustin secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'action et des comptes
publics
merci à madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur chevrollier vous dresser un
tableau sombre d'une situation qui n'est
pas la situation des comptes français
cette situation vous décrivez n'est pas
la vraie situation et vous permettrez d
d'illustrer cette affirmation à mon tour
par quatre chiffres
d'abord pour dire que en 2018 l'année
comptable s'est terminée avec un déficit
de 2 5% du pib au lieu des 2,7 prévu
dans le plf
c'est la deuxième année consécutive que
la france respecte son engagement à être
en dessous de 3%
ça n'était pas arrivé depuis 2006 la
deuxième chose je voudrais souligner
c'est que en 2018 toujours la dépendance
de la dépense publique pardon en volume
a diminué de 0 3%
et c'est la première fois de l'histoire
contemporaine cela s'explique par la
maîtrise des dépenses de l'état cela
s'explique par le fait que les
collectivités ont maîtrisé leurs
dépenses de fonctionnement avec une
augmentation de seulement 0,7 pour cent
et de 0,3 pour cent pour celle des
collectivités qui ont accepté le
principe de la contractualisation les
comptes de la sécurité sociale se sont
améliorées de presque 4 milliards
d'euros par rapport à 2019 et le taux de
prélèvements obligatoires est passé de
45 2 à 45% du pib ce qui signifie que
nous avons commencé à diminuer la
pression fiscale sur nos compatriotes et
sur les contribuables
ces quatre chiffres monsieur le sénateur
illustre le fait que ce que vous avez
décrit comme situation n'est pas la
réalité de la situation des comptes
publics
vous nous interroger vous interroger le
premier ministre sur la france que nous
voulons laisser et la france plutôt que
nous voulons construire si vous me
permettez cette nuance nous voulons
construire une france qui soit maîtresse
de son destin
je ne sois pas à la merci des marchés
qui ne soit pas la merci d'un
endettement puis trop important que de
génération en génération nous avons
transmis sur nos enfants nos
petits-enfants et les générations
suivantes
nous voulons une france où la dépense
publique soit efficace une france où la
dépense publique doit aussi signer ni
synonyme pardon de solidarité
d'attention aux plus fragiles et
d'accompagnement du développement et du
progrès de chacun dépend de notre
société
ces objectifs nous les poursuivrons avec
de la rigueur avec la maîtrise des
comptes je le répète les deux exercices
2007 et 2008 et l'exercice que nous
vivons en 2019 à l'équipe bis de
financement des mesures que j'ai évoqués
en réponse à la question la sénatrice
dernier démontre que nous pouvons y
arriver sans renoncer à nos objectifs ni
comptables ni politique
la parole est à madame jacques gabel
ah pardon pardon vous avez serait second
pour vous les petits 12 ans prix chers
collègues
merci mais la présidente monsieur le
ministre vous serez jugés sur les
résultats de votre politique à la fin du
quinquennat aujourd'hui vous ne
maîtrisez pas la dépense publique alors
que vous devriez la diminuer la majorité
sénatoriale vous fait des propositions
ecoutez-nous et de plus votre
gouvernement est prêt dans la république
donne des leçons à nos partenaires
européens
au lieu de montrer l'exemple sur la
gestion publique